From the day we arrive
On the planet
And blinking
Step into the sun
There's more to see
than can ever be seen
More to do
than can ever be done
There's far too much
to take in here
More to find
than can ever be found
But the sun rolling high
Through the sapphire sky
Keeps great and small
on the endless round
It's the circle of life
And it moves us all
Through despair and hope
Through faith and love
Till we find our place
On the path unwinding
In the circle
The circle of life
It's the circle of life
And it moves us all
Through despair and hope
Through faith and love
Till we find our place
On the path unwinding
In the circle
The circle of life
Life's not fair...
is it, my little friend?
While some are
born to feast...
others spend their lives
in the dark,
begging for scraps.
The way I see it...
you and I
are exactly the same.
We both want to
find a way out.
The king approaches!
This is not a drill.
His Majesty has requested
an audience.
Upon his entrance,
you will rise and genuflect.
Zazu...
you've made me lose my lunch.
You will answer to Mufasa
for missing the ceremony
this morning.
I answer to no one.
Scar? Scar. Scar.
No, no.
Don't look at me like that.
Are you hungry, Zazu?
Perhaps we could have
a bite together!
You can't eat me!
It is forbidden to eat
a member of the king's court!
Ow! No, please! Stop it!
Scar!
Well, look who's come down
to mingle with the commoners.
Sarabi and I didn't see you
at the presentation of Simba.
Was that today?
Must've slipped my mind.
Of course
I meant no disrespect
towards His Majesty or Sarabi.
As you know, I have tremendous
respect for the queen.
As the king's brother,
you should've been
first in line.
I was first in line.
Or don't you remember?
That is, until the precious
prince arrived.
Don't turn your back on me,
Scar.
Oh, no, Mufasa,
perhaps you shouldn't
turn your back on me.
Is that a challenge?
I wouldn't dream
of challenging you again.
A wise decision.
You are no match
for His Royalness.
Well, as far as brains go,
I got the lion's share.
But when it comes
to brute strength,
I'm afraid my big brother...
will always rule.
Not always, Scar.
One day,
it'll be my son who rules.
Simba will be your king.
Then long live the king.
- What am I gonna do with him?
- Oh, come on.
We both know he should've been
expelled from the Pride Lands
long ago.
He's my brother, Zazu.
This is his home.
As long as I am king,
that will never change.
Well, there's one
in every family, sire.
I had a cousin who thought
he was a woodpecker.
He slammed his head
into trees,
and our beaks
aren't built for it.
He was concussed regularly.
Oh, you've gone.
Uh, sire, coming back!
Subtitle | www.movieddl.me
Simba.
Dad, you awake?
Dad, wake up!
Dad!
Dad, Dad, Dad!
Your son's awake.
Before sunrise, he's your son.
Come on, Dad, let's go.
You said I could
patrol with you today.
And today has started.
You promised!
You up?
Let's do this!
- Let's do this.
- So, what's first?
Give orders for the hunt?
Chase away evil intruders?
Dad! You're going
the wrong way!
Dad?
I'm not supposed
to go up here.
Look, Simba.
Everything the light touches
is our kingdom.
You rule all of that?
Yes.
But a king's time as ruler...
rises and falls like the sun.
One day, Simba...
the sun will set
on my time here...
and will rise with you
as the new king.
All of this will belong to me?
It belongs to no one,
but will be yours to protect.
A great responsibility.
Everything the light touches?
Those trees?
And the watering hole?
And that mountain?
And beyond those shadows?
You must not go there, Simba.
But I thought a king could do
whatever he wants.
Take any territory.
While others search
for what they can take...
a true king
searches for what he can give.
Everything you see
exists together
in a delicate balance.
As king, you need to
understand that balance...
and respect
all the creatures...
from the crawling ant
to the leaping antelope.
But, Dad,
don't we eat the antelope?
Yes, Simba.
But let me explain.
When we die,
our bodies become the grass...
and the antelope
eat the grass...
and so we are all connected
in the great circle of life.
- Sire!
- Morning, Zazu.
Do you have
the morning report?
Yes, sire.
Ten flamingos
are taking a stand.
Two giraffe
were caught necking.
The buzz from the bees...
is that the leopards
are in a bit of a spot.
Ready for some fun?
The birds are tweeting
at 4:00 in the morning.
I'm like, "Birds, we get it."
Stay low to the ground.
I got this.
Check the wind,
the shadows...
and wait for
the perfect moment to pounce.
The cheetahs stole
the baboons' dinner,
and now the baboons
are going ape.
Of course, as I say,
cheetahs never prosper.
That's what I say.
Do you get...
I'll say it again.
Cheetahs never...
Come on! It's the news!
That's very good!
Sire!
Hyenas in the Pride Lands.
They're on the hunt!
- Where's Sarabi?
- She's leading the charge.
Zazu, take Simba home.
Dad, let me come! I can help.
No, son.
You stay with the other cubs.
I am not a cub.
Come on.
Let's go home.
Here we are.
Now you go along
and play with the other cubs.
Great.
If you wish
to kill something...
you might want
to stay downwind.
I know how to hunt,
Uncle Scar.
Well, let's hope we're never
attacked by a beetle.
Go back to your den, Simba.
I don't babysit.
Babysit? I'm gonna be the king
of Pride Rock.
My dad showed me
the whole kingdom.
Said I'm going to rule it all.
Is that so?
Think about it.
When I'm king,
I'll have to give you orders.
Tell you what to do.
How weird is that?
You've no idea.
So, your dad showed you
the whole kingdom?
Did he show you the shadows
beyond the northern borders?
No. He said I can't go there.
Ever.
And he's absolutely right.
An elephant graveyard is
no place for a young prince.
An elephant graveyard? Whoa.
Oh, dear. I've said too much.
Though I suppose you'd have
found out sooner or later...
you being king and all.
You've been there?
We've all been there.
And it's no place for a cub.
All those rotting bones...
and burning pools
of oozing mud.
Rotting bones?
Oozing mud?
Promise me
you'll stay away, Simba.
Now, you run along.
And remember...
it's our little secret...
Your Majesty.
Nala! Come on.
We have to go.
- Where?
- Watering hole.
Simba, she's having her bath.
And it's time for yours.
But, Mom...
I can do it myself.
Hold still.
You're messing up my mane!
Come on. Behind the ears.
Come on, Mom!
See? All clean. Can we go?
There's no hyenas.
You just chased them all off.
Just to the watering hole
and no further.
And stay downwind.
And one more little thing.
Zazu will be going with you.
Zazu?
Zazu goes...
or you don't.
Come along. Keep up.
Let's move in a unit.
Okay, buddy system.
So, where are we really going?
How did you know?
You hate the water.
I heard
about this place, Nala.
The most incredible,
amazing...
Just tell me where.
An elephant graveyard.
Whoa. How far is it?
Not far. Just to the shadows.
But don't worry,
everyone's been there.
We've never been
that far before.
- What if we get lost?
- Relax, Nala.
I patrolled the entire kingdom
this morning with my dad.
There's nothing
to worry about.
Well, there is one thing.
We have an imminent threat.
Something is approaching.
Oh, wait, scratch that.
That's my own shadow.
How we getting rid
of the dodo?
Trust me, I got this.
Follow me to freedom.
Oh, how lovely it is...
to see the future king
with his future queen.
I could just molt.
What do you mean,
"future queen"?
Well, one day the two of you
will be betrothed.
Intended. Affianced.
Simba, you speak bird?
Married!
Come on.
One day you will be married.
To each other.
- Ugh!
- Ew!
Mmm-mmm. That's not
gonna happen, Zazu.
Never ever.
Nala and I are friends.
And besides,
she's afraid of rhinos!
And he's never eaten
an impala.
I've tried it once.
We are never
getting married, Zazu.
A monarch
who ignores tradition?
With an attitude like that,
I'm afraid you'll be
a pretty pathetic king.
Well, I'm not letting anyone
tell me where to go,
what to do...
and even who to marry.
There will never be a king
like me.
Simba, you can't escape
your destiny.
Just watch.
I'm gonna be a mighty king
So enemies beware
Well, I've
never seen a king of beasts
With quite so little hair
I'm gonna be the main event
Like no king was before
I'm brushing up
on looking down
Working on my roar
Thus far
a rather uninspiring thing
Oh, I just can't wait
to be king
You have rather a long way
to go, young master.
If you think...
No one saying "do this"
Now, when I said that...
No one saying "be there"
What I meant was...
No one saying
"stop that"
No one saying "see here"
Now see here!
Free to run around
all day
Well,
that's definitely out.
Free to do it all my way
I think it's time
that you and I
Arranged a heart-to-heart
Kings don't need advice
From little horn bills
for a start
If this is where the monarchy
is headed, count me out
Out of service
Out of Africa
I wouldn't hang about
This child is getting
wildly out of wing
Simba!
Oh, I just can't wait
to be king
Simba!
I can't see you, Simba.
You must be in my sight
at all times.
I've lost him!
I know what you're doing!
Where are you going, Simba?
Come on!
You can't hide from me, Simba.
It is my sworn duty
to keep you safe.
You listen to me right now.
I'm sorry to flutter about
in your face,
have you seen...
He's a little lion.
He's small,
but he's cute.
Everybody look left
Everybody look right
Everywhere you look I'm
Standing in the spotlight
Not yet.
Let every creature go
for broke and sing
Let's hear it in the herd
and on the wing
I see you down there!
It's gonna be King Simba's
finest fling
Oh, I just can't wait
to be king
Simba!
He just can't wait to be king
Oh, I just can't wait
Just can't wait
To be king
I've lost him!
Mufasa's gonna have
my feathers.
This is not good!
Simba, we really lost him.
I know what you're thinking.
"The future king is a genius."
You can't be serious.
You would've never gotten away
without your queen.
Aren't you
forgetting something?
There is no queen.
You could say that again.
I'd rather marry an aardvark.
Good luck finding one
that will say yes.
Good luck getting out of here
without a bruising.
Give it your best shot.
Pinned ya!
You owe me an apology.
Never!
Pinned ya.
Again.
Nala, stop!
What is that?
You're not gonna trick me,
Simba.
I know that there's nothing...
This must be it.
Come on!
Simba, we're way
beyond the Pride Lands.
We found it, Nala.
You know what this means?
It means we can go home.
It means they won't
treat us like cubs anymore.
Simba, get down!
It could be dangerous.
Danger?
I laugh in the face of danger.
Cool!
You hear that, Nala?
Simba, come on!
You've proved
how brave you are.
Now the sun is going down,
I'm not just
gonna sit here and...
Well, look at this.
We weren't
expecting guests today.
Would you two cubs...
like to stay for dinner?
Yeah, stay for dinner.
'Cause you look
like a midnight snack!
Can you just give me
a little bit of space?
I'm helping.
We have talked
about this before.
I come in alone.
I'm the lead distraction
so everyone can circle.
Okay, okay. Sorry.
Don't be sorry.
Just do it.
Now, this is a meal
I've waited my whole life for.
What an unexpected treat,
to eat the son of a king.
Wait a second, the king?
As in you-know-who?
Who rules you-know-where?
Mufasa does not rule me!
You can't do anything to me!
'Cause I'm the future king!
He's telling me what to do.
His father's strength
flickering inside.
I wonder...
how all that bravery
will taste.
Let them go, Shenzi!
They made a mistake,
a horrible mistake!
But if you do this, you will
start a war with Mufasa!
Hyenas and lions
have been at war
since the beginning of time.
But Mufasa's bloodline
will end here!
Run!
Don't let them get away!
Come on!
Did you hear that?
The future king!
Oh, don't hurt me!
Do it again!
If you ever come
near my son again...
No, Mufasa. Never.
Never again.
You've been warned, Shenzi.
I thought
you were very brave.
Zazu?
Take Nala back to Pride Rock.
Yes, sire.
Don't be too hard
on him, sire.
I remember a cub,
a certain headstrong cub...
who was always getting
into scrapes.
And he achieved
some prominence,
did he not, sire?
I have to teach my son
a lesson.
Nala, come along.
Simba?
You deliberately disobeyed me.
I know.
You could
have been killed.
And what's worse,
you put Nala in danger.
Do you understand
what's at stake?
You jeopardized
the future of our pride.
I just wanted to show you
I could do it.
That I could be brave
like you.
I'm only brave
when I have to be,
when there's no other choice.
But you're not scared
of anything.
I was today.
You were?
Yes. I thought
I might lose you.
I guess
even kings get scared, huh?
More than you could ever know.
- But guess what?
- What?
I think those hyenas
were even scareder.
That's 'cause nobody messes
with your dad.
Come here.
- Dad?
- Uh-huh?
- We're pals, right?
- Right.
And we'll always
be together...
right?
Simba, let me tell you
something my father told me.
Look at the stars.
The great kings of the past...
look down on us
from those stars.
- Really?
- Yes.
So whenever you feel alone...
just remember
that those kings...
will always be up there
to guide you.
And so will I.
But I can't see them, Dad.
Keep looking, son.
Keep looking.
Mufasa is strong.
Like, way stronger than us.
- Please give me some space.
- What?
You could lay anywhere
in this cave.
- Where do you want me to...
- I need some personal space.
- Okay?
- Okay.
Not to take anything away
from you. You were great.
But he is...
See, now I know you're
doing this on purpose.
Very brave, too.
Tough, good energy.
Now you're just
being spiteful.
Good posture.
Next time I see Mufasa...
I'm gonna teach him a lesson
he will never forget.
Well, you're in luck!
He's right behind ya.
Mufasa?
That's not the king.
You fools have stripped your
land of every living thing.
And yet I send
two little cubs your way...
and they come back alive.
I guess
we'll have to eat you instead.
Why eat one meal...
when you can be feasting
the rest of your lives?
What could you possibly
offer us?
A place where you can fill
your bellies.
Where everything
the light touches
is yours for the kill.
The Pride Lands
are not yours to give.
The king controls
those hunting grounds.
That's why
we're going to kill him.
Mufasa has always shown
too much restraint...
when it comes to hunting.
When I am king...
the mighty will be free to
take whatever they want.
Because a hyena's belly
is never full.
Mufasa's far too powerful
to challenge.
Mufasa is yesterday's message
A clapped-out,
distracted regime
Whose failings
undoubtedly presage
The need for a dif'rent dream
Yes, leonine times
are a-changing
Which means
that hyenas must too
My vision is clear
and wide-ranging
And even encompasses you
So prepare
for the coup of the century
Prepare for the murkiest scam
Meticulous planning
Tenacity spanning
Decades of denial
ls simply why I'll
Be king
Undisputed
Respected
Saluted
And seen for the wonder I am
Yes, my teeth
and ambitions are bared
Be prepared
- Be prepared
Yes, our teeth and ambitions
are bared
Be prepared
My dad was pretty upset
with me.
That's why we're here, Simba.
I think I know a way for you
to make it up to him.
A gift that will make him
forget it ever happened.
But he's the king.
What could I give him?
Your roar.
My roar?
Yes!
Did you hear that?
This gorge is where all lions
come to find their roar.
All lions?
Even my dad?
Even Mufasa came here
when he was your age.
Refused to leave...
until his roar could be heard
above the rim.
All the way up there?
That's when you know
you've found it.
With a little practice...
you'll never be called
a cub again.
Watch this.
You'll get it, Simba.
Just takes time.
I'll check on you later.
Dad will be so proud,
won't he?
It's a gift
he'll never forget.
Mufasa! Quick!
Stampede in the gorge!
Simba's down there!
Simba?
I'll find him.
Zazu!
Hold on!
Help is coming!
There he is!
On that tree!
I'm coming, Simba!
Hold on!
I'll help them, Zazu!
You get the pride!
Go!
Dad!
Simba!
Come to me, son.
Jump!
Dad!
Scar!
Help me.
Long live the king!
No!
Dad?
Come on, wake up.
Help! Somebody help!
Simba!
What have you done?
It was a stampede.
He tried to save me.
It was an accident.
- I didn't mean for it to...
- Of course you didn't.
No one ever means
for these things to happen.
But the king is dead...
and if it weren't for you...
he'd still be alive.
Your father had such hopes
for you...
gave you so many chances.
And this is how you repay him.
I didn't know.
Oh, what will
your mother think?
A son who causes
his father's death.
A boy who kills a king.
What am I gonna do?
Run.
Run away, Simba.
Run away and never return!
Kill him.
Go down
and make sure he's dead.
Seriously?
Oh, I'm sorry.
That's a good distance
right there.
Okay.
No little cub
could survive that fall.
Listen,
we're gonna tell her...
we went down there
and we ate him.
Uh-huh. That's perfect,
'cause I am starving!
We're not gonna eat him.
Simba is dead.
That's all she ever
has to know.
Works for me.
Mufasa's death
is a terrible tragedy.
The greatest leader
the pride has ever known.
To lose a brother...
such a deep, personal loss.
And little Simba,
who had barely begun to live.
A cub whose blood
held our future.
It's almost too much
to endure.
I only wish I had gotten
to the gorge in time...
been there to save them.
And so it is
with a heavy heart...
that I must assume the throne.
Mufasa and Simba are gone...
which means I am your king.
But I must admit...
I cannot bear
this burden alone.
And I will need some help...
to ensure
the safety of the pride.
Nala, stay close.
And so, from the ashes
of this tragedy...
we shall welcome
the dawning of a new era.
A great...
and glorious future!
Oh, dear.
I missed 'em!
I'm gonna get one of
those vultures one day.
I'm gonna get one!
I don't know why it's
so important to you.
I just feel like it would
make me feel better.
Oh, no.
It's a little lion!
- That is not a lion.
- Well then, go check it out.
- What is it?
- That is not a lion,
it's a furry bird!
It looks like a lion!
That's not a lion. Let me get
a closer look. Excuse me.
All right, let me see
what we're dealing with here.
It's a lion!
- Run for your life, Pumbaa!
- Wait! Hey, Timon.
Wait, Timon, wait!
It's a little lion!
It gets bigger.
Can we keep him?
Can we please keep him?
Oh, oh, okay. I promise
I'll walk him every day!
If he makes a little mess,
I'll clean it up.
You'll be his little mess!
He's gonna eat you and then
use my body as a toothpick!
But one day,
when he's big and strong,
he'll be on our side!
I've got it.
What if he's on our side?
Hear me out!
Having a ferocious lion around
might not be such a bad idea!
Well then, can we keep him?
Yes, of course
we can keep him!
My God, who is the brains
of this operation?
We're gonna name him Fred!
Who are you?
Uh, we're the guys
who saved your life.
Yes.
Risked everything.
Fought off angry vultures!
Hordes of them. Flocks.
I'm Pumbaa.
- This is Timon.
- Did I mention
that we saved your life?
It doesn't matter.
Whoa. How bleak is that?
It doesn't even matter?
Like I don't have enough
that I'm dealing with, right?
Now his problems
are my problems?
But we can help him. We're
in a position to help him.
So, how are you,
in as few words as possible?
I did something terrible.
I don't wanna talk about it.
Look, kid,
we've all made mistakes.
Uh, there must be something
we can do, right?
Not unless you can change
the past.
Well, you know,
that's a lot to ask...
That's pretty hard.
That's a biggie.
...if I'm being honest.
I mean, change the past?
It already happened.
Yeah, so you can't
change that.
But you know
what you can change?
The future.
That's our specialty.
Kind of our thing.
How can you change something
that hasn't happened?
Well, to change the future,
you gotta put your past
behind you.
Way behind.
Look, kid, bad things happen
and you can't do anything
about it, right?
Right.
Wrong! When the world
turns its back on you...
you turn your back
on the world!
And only embrace what's next!
And turn the "what"
into "so what?"
Well, that's not
what I was taught.
Well, then maybe
you need a new lesson.
Repeat after me, kid.
Hakuna matata.
- What?
- Hakuna matata.
Hakuna matata.
Most people
get a bigger reaction
when we say it the first...
Okay, well anyway.
Hakuna matata.
Some people
start clapping immediately.
It means "no worries."
One and a...
I do the counting here.
- I wanna count!
- Why don't we count together?
- Okay, that's a good idea.
- All right.
One and a two and a...
Hakuna matata
What a wonderful phrase
It ain't no passing craze
It means no worries
For the rest of your days
It's our problem-free
Philosophy
Hakuna matata
- Hakuna matata?
- Yeah, it's our motto.
What's a motto?
Nothin'.
What's-a-motto with you?
- Nice.
- Boom!
Those two words
will solve all your problems.
Yeah. Take Pumbaa here.
Why,
when he was a young warthog
When I was a young warthog
- How are you feeling?
- It's an emotional story.
He found his aroma
lacked a certain appeal
He could clear the savannah
after every meal
I'm a sensitive soul
Although I seem thick-skinned
And it hurt that my friends
never stood downwind
I was always here for you
and I resent that.
-And, oh, the shame
- Yes, he was ashamed
I thought of changing my name
I mean, to what, "Brad"?
And I got downhearted
Ev'ry time that I farted
Are you gonna stop me?
No, I'm not! You disgust me!
Hakuna matata
What a wonderful phrase
Ain't no passing craze
It means no worries
For the rest of your days
Yeah, sing it, kid
It's our problem-free
Philosophy
Hakuna matata
Welcome to
our humble home.
You live here?
Well, we live
wherever we want.
We do as we please.
It's beautiful.
Yeah,
it's really nice, huh?
Everyone, this is Simba.
That, my friend, is a lion.
What about food?
Have you thought
about feeding that thing?
Yeah, I'm starved!
I could eat a whole zebra.
Here we go.
Uh, no, no, no, kid,
we're fresh out of zebra.
Any antelope?
- Uh-oh.
- No, listen, kid...
if you want to live with us,
you have to eat like us.
And most importantly,
not eat us!
This looks like a good
spot to rustle up some grub!
- Yeah!
- It's perfect!
Step aside, fellas!
Ugh. What's that?
Ooh. Too chewy.
This one's got some nuttiness!
Mmm. Now that's what
I call umami!
Slimy, yet satisfying.
Mmm. Extra crunchy.
- They're local.
- Yeah. Oh, are they?
They're from right there.
I'm telling ya, kid,
this is the great life.
No rules.
No responsibilities.
Ooh!
The little cream-filled kind.
I love these!
- Those are good.
- I love these.
Those are the best.
Can I have the head?
Well, kid?
Oh, well.
Hakuna matata.
Slimy...
yet satisfying.
- That's it!
- We didn't lie!
Egg sac!
I got an egg sac!
Hakuna matata
It means no worries
For the rest of your days
It's our problem-free
Philosophy
-Hakuna matata, oh
- Hakuna matata, hakuna matata
-Hakuna matata, yeah
-Hakuna matata
- Hakuna matata, hakuna matata
Hakuna matata
-It means no worries
- Hakuna matata
-For the rest of your days
- Hakuna matata, hakuna matata
Hakuna
It's our problem-free
Philosophy
Hakuna matata
One more time.
Oh, no,
I think we did it. Yeah.
I think we got this one.
But we're just getting
in the groove, guys.
No, let's leave 'em
wanting more.
Yeah, you've grown
400 pounds since we started.
Meanwhile I look
exactly the same.
It means no worries
Will you tell him
to stop?
But you insisted
we sing the song.
I insisted?
You started singing it!
Well,
it's our signature song...
we shouldn't be sharing it
with everyone.
Look at that sunset.
But it's our signature
song, so we have to.
Look, just tell him to stop.
It means no worries
Oh, now he's riffing,
Pumbaa.
This is a nightmare.
It actually is
becoming better and better.
Nala.
Come.
Sit with us.
Zazu, where have you been?
I'm sorry, Nala.
I came as soon as I could.
The morning report, Zazu.
Your Majesty, the Pride Lands
are in imminent danger.
The hyenas are chasing off
the last of the herds.
The bird's back!
Get him!
Don't come here again,
unless you want to be eaten!
We have to do something,
Sarabi. We have to fight!
Nala. Scar is the king.
But you are our queen!
We should leave
before it's too late!
We must all stay together
and protect the Pride Lands.
This is our home.
We must never abandon it.
This isn't the home
I remember.
Our time will come, Nala.
Be patient.
Sarabi.
The king wishes to see you.
Don't go.
I'm not afraid of him.
Won't you join me, Sarabi?
There's plenty to go around.
You're over hunting, Scar.
I've simply perfected
the kill.
With the help of my army.
You're killing everything.
Don't you see? There is nobody
to challenge me.
We can finally take
whatever we want.
We?
Long ago
you chose Mufasa over me.
But now there is a new king.
So stop being so selfish.
You are the selfish one.
The other lions look to you.
As long as you resist
they will reject me.
Take your place by my side,
and we will feast together.
I will never be your queen!
Then from now on...
the lions will eat
after the hyenas.
And they don't
leave much behind.
Just what do you think
you are doing, young lady?
Go away, Zazu.
I'm going to find help.
I will very much not go away.
I am sworn to protect you and
must order you back to bed.
I don't need
protecting anymore.
Uh, Scar!
Uh, wonderful to see you.
Uh,
sorry to drop in like this!
Ah!
Have I ever told you
about my brother
who thought he was
a woodpecker?
Nala...
Oh, I'm gonna get ya!
I'm gonna get ya!
Oh, I got ya!
Oh.
Simba! It's you!
Did you see that?
Man, that butterfly
was right there!
I almost had him.
I thought it was a lion.
You know,
the other kind of lion.
You know, a real lion?
I mean, not that
you're not a real lion.
But you know,
the kind that eats...
I'm gonna go.
Hey, where you going?
You wanna get some grubs?
What's up with that guy?
Um, Simba...
How can I say this?
- He's prey.
- Yeah.
And he is never gonna want to
frolic with a carnivore.
No. You two will never frolic.
Why not?
You see, in nature
there's a delicate balance.
Oh, yeah. The circle of life.
I know that.
- No.
- No, no, no.
I don't know where
you're getting "circle" from.
No, yeah.
There's no circle of life.
- No, it's no circle.
- No, not at all.
- In fact, it's the opposite.
- Yeah.
- It's a line.
It's a meaningless line
of indifference.
And we're all just running
towards the end of the line.
And then one day we'll reach
the end, and that'll be it.
- That's it.
- Line over!
- Nothing.
- Nada.
And you can really
just kinda...
do your own thing
and fend for yourself...
'cause your line doesn't
affect anyone else's lines.
You're alive and then
you're not. Like this guy.
Mmm.
You sure it's not a circle?
That we're all connected?
A circle would mean
we're all this.
That would mean
what I do affects him...
affects that thing,
affects that thing.
Yeah. No.
That's not how it goes.
Which would make
doing whatever we wanted
not that cool.
Let me simplify this for you.
- Life is meaningless.
- Yes.
That's why you just gotta
look out for yourself.
That's why you do you, Simba.
Yeah, Simba,
for the first time...
we're entrusting you to
make a plan for us today.
This is important. Think about
all you've been taught.
What do you wanna do?
Absolutely nothing.
- Whoo-hoo!
- Exactly! He gets it!
Jackpot!
Out of my way!
- Crunchy!
- All right! Time to eat!
Oh.
Hello!
Nice one, Simba.
Oh, thanks.
Must've been the termites.
Or the crickets.
And you wonder why I prefer
to sleep underground.
Hey, Timon.
Do you ever look up there
and wonder
what those sparkly dots are?
Oh, Pumbaa.
I don't wonder. I know.
Really? What are they?
They're fireflies.
Fireflies that got stuck on
that big, bluish-black thing.
Oh.
I guess that makes sense.
I always thought
they were balls of gas
burning
billions of miles away.
Oh, Pumbaa, why is everything
always gas with you?
I know.
- What do you think, Simba?
- Yeah.
Oh, I don't know.
But somebody once told me...
the great kings of the past
are up there...
and they're all
watching over us.
That's a good one!
That's insane!
Royal dead guys
watching over us!
Well, I hope they don't
fall out of the sky!
Hang on, Your Majesty!
Don't let go!
Oh, that would be a mess.
Oh, man!
I mean, Simba,
think about it.
Why would a bunch of kings
be looking out for us?
- We're outcasts.
- Royal warthogs!
- I can't! I can't!
- I can't! I actually can't.
- I can't.
- No, you can. I can't.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
That's stupid.
I'm gonna go get some grubs
or something.
- What did you say to him?
- I don't know.
As you were saying it,
I thought,
"This won't end well."
- You just start laughing.
- You laughed too.
I did not. I would never.
Man, I blew it.
Simba.
Simba is alive!
A-weema-weh
Wee
Uh wee bum bum buh-weh
In the jungle,
the mighty jungle
The lion sleeps tonight
In the jungle,
the quiet jungle
The lion sleeps tonight
Wee
Uh wee bum bum buh-weh
Near the village,
the peaceful village
The lion sleeps tonight
Near the village,
the quiet village
The lion sleeps tonight
Wee
Uh wee bum bum buh-weh
Pumbaa!
Run for your life!
Run, Pumbaa, run!
Timon, help!
Pumbaa!
Pumbaa?
I'm gonna die!
I'm coming, Pumbaa!
Hang in there!
Move! Move! Move!
No!
Oh, no! Oh, no!
Nala?
Simba?
Is that really you?
Yeah.
It's me, Simba!
Nala, what're you doing?
Oh, my...
I don't believe it!
Look at you!
Pumbaa...
I don't think
you're getting eaten.
Oh, where have you been?
I thought you were dead!
You thought he was
dead. I thought I was dead!
I thought
you were gonna eat me.
What fun!
I'm so sorry,
before we move on,
how do you two
know each other?
Timon, Pumbaa...
I want you to meet
my best friend, Nala.
Best friend? Well, that hurts.
Nala, you're gonna
love it here!
This place is amazing.
It's everything
you could ever want.
Simba, we need to leave.
Scar has taken over
with the hyenas.
You have to take your place
as king.
King? Simba?
We kneel before you
as loyal servants.
Pumbaa, relax.
She's wrong.
Lady, you've got
your lions crossed.
Nice.
Seeing you again,
you don't know what this will
mean to everyone.
What this means to me.
You have to come home.
This is my home.
Please stay.
This place is incredible.
I know you'll love it.
I can't.
Come on!
At least
let me show you around.
Where are you going?
Simba, it's so beautiful.
I can see what's happening
I can't. What?
And they don't have a clue
Who's "they"?
They'll fall in love
And here's the bottom line
Our trio's down to two
Oh, I get it.
The sweet caress of twilight
Yeah.
There's magic ev'rywhere
It's ev'rywhere.
And with all this
romantic atmosphere
Disaster's in the air
Can you feel the love tonight?
The peace the evening brings
The world for once
in perfect harmony
With all its living things
So many things
to tell her
But how to make her see
The truth about my past?
Impossible
She'd turn away from me
He's holding back,
he's hiding
But what, I can't decide
Why won't he be the king
I know he is?
The king I see inside?
Can you feel
the love tonight?
The peace the evening brings
The world for once
in perfect harmony
With all its living things
Can you feel the love tonight?
You needn't look too far
Stealing through
the night's uncertainties
Love is where they are
And if he falls
in love tonight
It can be assumed
His carefree days
with us are history
In short, our pal is doomed
I told you.
Isn't it great here?
You know, maybe it could be
like this forever.
It's amazing.
But there's something
I don't understand.
If you've been alive
all this time...
why haven't you come home?
We've really needed you.
They're fine, all right?
Nobody needs me.
You're the king.
Nala, Scar is the king.
Simba, he's decimated
the Pride Lands.
There's no food, no water...
There's nothing I can do.
What about your mother?
This is your responsibility.
You need to challenge Scar.
I can't go back. Ever.
Why?
Because of what happened
at the gorge?
Scar told us that...
You wouldn't understand!
None of it matters. Okay?
Hakuna matata.
What?
It's something
I learned out here, okay?
You see,
sometimes bad things happen,
and there's nothing
you can do about it.
So, why worry?
Why worry?
What happened to you?
You're not
the Simba I remember.
And I never will be.
Are you satisfied?
No, I'm disappointed.
You know, now you're starting
to sound like my father.
Good. I'm glad one of us does.
You have no idea
what I've been through!
I came here looking for help.
I guess I made a mistake.
Goodbye, Simba.
"Disappointed"?
She wants me to go home?
I am home.
"Best friend"?
I don't need best friends.
I don't need anybody.
Never did.
Go away.
Going away will not
answer the question.
What question?
Who are you?
I know exactly who I am.
The question is, who are you?
I'm nobody. So leave me alone.
All right?
Everybody is somebody.
Even a nobody.
Yeah,
I think you're confused.
I am confused?
You don't even know
who you are.
Oh. And I suppose you do?
I held the son of Mufasa.
You knew my father?
Correction.
I know your father.
He died a long time ago.
He's alive!
And I can take you to him.
Follow me. I will show you!
Whoa. Hey, hey, hey!
If you can keep up!
Wait!
Follow me!
Quickly, quickly!
Come through!
Hey! Slow down!
Hey, you better hurry.
Hold on.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Come.
Your father is waiting.
Do you see him?
I don't see anything.
Look closer.
You see?
He lives in you.
Simba.
Dad?
You must take your place
in the circle of life.
I can't.
You must remember who you are.
The one true king.
I'm sorry.
I don't know
how to be like you.
As king, I was most proud
of one thing.
Having you as my son.
That was a long time ago.
No, Simba. That is forever.
Please.
Don't leave me again.
I never left you.
And never will.
Remember who you are.
Remember.
And so, I ask again.
Who are you?
I am Simba.
Son of Mufasa.
Yeah
Spirit
Watch the heavens open
Yeah
Spirit
Can you hear it calling?
Yeah
Simba?
Come on!
What are you waiting for?
Let's go home!
Spirit
Watch the heavens open, open
Yeah
Your destiny is coming close
Stand up and fight
So, go in to a far-off land
And be one with the great I am
I didn't wanna believe you.
So, what are you gonna do?
My father
once told me to protect
everything the light touches.
If I don't fight for it,
who will?
I will.
It's going to be dangerous.
Danger? Ha!
I laugh in the face of danger.
It can't be!
Hello, Zazu.
Your Majesty.
Welcome home.
We're here!
Oh, everyone, calm down.
We're here.
The backup has arrived!
What are you guys doing here?
- Um, we were not worried!
- Um... No, not worried.
- 'Cause no worries.
- Nope. Hakuna matata.
- We were concerned, because...
- Because, you know...
You're our friend.
What about the meaningless
line of indifference?
Well, we were thinking...
- maybe it curves a little bit.
- That's a good point.
I mean, Simba, look,
I'm happy to admit
when Pumbaa's wrong...
and this is
one of those instances.
What? That wasn't my thing.
You told me about the line.
Wait, hold on.
Now, this is the place
you're fighting for?
Yes, Timon.
This is my home.
Is it behind
that terrifying rock?
Talk about your fixer-upper.
I like what
you've done with it,
although a bit heavy
on the carcass.
Hey, hey, look. A bird.
Timon, Pumbaa, this is Zazu.
Oh, wow! It's a puffin.
Charming.
Simba, we are with you
until the end.
We are at your service,
my liege!
Follow me.
Hyenas everywhere.
I hope it's a quick death.
You know,
just not a lot of chewing.
What's your plan
for getting us
past the slobbering guards?
Live bait.
That's a great idea.
Those guys could never
resist fresh meat.
So all we need to do is find
something that's, like, big...
and plump, and juicy.
Maybe like a gnu?
Why is everyone looking at me?
It is with deepest pride
and greatest pleasure...
that we proudly present...
your dinner.
Be our guest
It's working, Pumbaa!
My old friend.
Sarabi,
why put yourself through this?
All you have to do
is be my queen.
You're suffering for what?
The memory of a life
you once knew?
A king you once loved?
I tried to make you understand
what a true king can be.
Scar, a true king's power
is his compassion.
I am ten times
the king Mufasa was!
You are nothing
compared to Mufasa!
Mufasa?
It can't be.
Get away from my mother.
Simba.
You're alive?
How can that be?
I'm here, Mother.
I'm home.
Simba...
I'm so happy to see you.
Alive.
Give me one good reason
why I shouldn't rip you apart.
I can give you more than one.
You see...
they think I'm king.
Well, we don't.
Your reign is over, Scar.
Simba is the rightful king!
If you wanna get him,
you have to get through us.
Are you with me, lions?
The choice is yours, Scar.
Step down or fight.
Must this all end in violence?
I'd hate to be responsible for
the death of a family member.
To feel the shame
of knowing...
I took the life
of someone I love.
I put all that behind me.
But have they
put it behind them?
Do your faithful subjects
know what you've done?
What is he talking about?
So you haven't told them
your little secret?
Well, Simba...
now's your chance to confess.
Tell them who's responsible
for Mufasa's death.
It was me.
It's not true.
Tell me it's not true.
It's true. I'm sorry.
He admits it.
Murderer!
No, no.
It was an accident.
If it weren't for you
the king would be alive.
It's your fault he's dead!
Do you deny it?
I'm not a murderer.
We should believe a son who
takes the life of a father?
We should believe a son
who takes the life of a king?
A son who abandons his mother?
No. I'm...
You're what? Say it!
Are you the king?
No. No, I'm...
- Are you the king?
- No, I'm...
- You're what? Say it!
- I'm...
I'm nothing.
Then bow to your king!
Simba!
This looks familiar.
Where have I seen this before?
Oh, yes, I remember.
This is the way Mufasa looked
before he died.
I looked down...
saw the fear in his eyes.
And here's my little secret.
I killed Mufasa.
No!
My father!
Your own brother!
How could you?
First he kills Mufasa...
and now he wants to kill me!
You killed him!
Tell them the truth!
Don't believe his lies!
Scar...
you told us you didn't get
to the gorge in time.
That's true!
Then how did you see
the look in Mufasa's eyes?
Murderer!
Kill them all!
Lions, attack!
Simba!
- Pumbaa, I think we lost them.
- That was terrifying.
Do you hear a low growl?
Looks like we'll be
having pig for dinner.
Plump and chubby.
Chubby?
- Did he just call me chubby?
- Uh-oh.
It sounded a lot like
he just said "chubby".
Which would be
a mistake because...
I will not be made to feel
ashamed of who I am!
Oh, boy.
I may run from hyenas...
but I will always
fight a bully!
- You feel better, Pumbaa?
- I do.
You got that
out of your system?
I did.
Now, this is a meal
I've waited my whole life for.
I've been waiting too.
And I'm not a cub anymore!
For king and country!
It's the bird!
I got him! I got him!
Tally-ho!
Oh! No! He's got me!
He's got me! Ooh!
Get that bird!
Please! Let's discuss this.
That never gets old!
It's over, Scar.
Have mercy.
I beg you.
Mercy?
After what you did?
It was the hyenas.
Those revolting scavengers
made me do it.
I was planning
on killing them all.
You fooled the hyenas.
Just like you fooled me.
Simba...
you wouldn't kill
your only uncle.
No, Scar.
I'm not like you.
Oh, Simba...
you are truly noble.
And I will make it up to you.
Just tell me how
I can prove myself.
Tell me what
you want me to do.
Run.
Run away, Scar.
Run away and never return.
Yes.
Of course.
As you wish...
Your Majesty.
Aah!
You can't win, Scar!
This is my kingdom!
My destiny!
My friends.
It will take some time,
but together
we will build our army.
"Friends", huh?
I thought you said we were
"revolting scavengers"?
Yeah.
That you wanted to kill us?
No.
No, let me explain.
I was trying to fool him.
We will rule together!
There's only one true thing
you ever said, Scar.
"A hyena's belly...
"is never full."
No!
Your Majesty.
Remember.
Till we find our place
On the path unwinding
In the circle
The circle of life
Circle of life
It's never
too late to turn things around
Recover, unravel the path
to confound
The doubters and losers
that line up despair
Who tell you it's over,
you're goin' nowhere
It's never too late, I hope
It's never too late
to get back on track
To get at least some,
if not all of it back
I thought I was happy,
and sometimes I was
But sadness is just
as important because
Got to carry the weight
and hope
It's never too late
Never too late
to fight the fight
to cheat the night
Never too late to win the day
Never too late to break away
Time will start
to move too fast
But time is now,
my friend
I'm a long way from the start
But further from the end
Oh, no, it's never too late
It's never too late
to get up off the ground
Don't have to be noticed,
don't have to be crowned
I did what I've done,
and I don't try to hide
I've lost many things,
but never my pride
It's never too late, I know
It's never too late
Never too late
to fight the fight
to cheat the night
Never too late to win the day
Never too late to break away
Time will start
to move too fast
But time is now,
my friend
I'm a long way from the start
But further from the end
Oh, no, it's never too late
Never too late
I used to say
I don't have time
I'm sleepin' tonight
A day doin' nothin'
is doin' it right
No hurry, no hurry,
it takes as long as it takes
You might as well sleep
for all the difference
it makes
I didn't find love
or peace on the breaks
These aren't excuses,
but a string of mistakes
I won't go back there
Not going back there
Never too late
to fight the fight
to cheat the night
Never too late to win the day
Never too late to break away
Never too late
to fight the fight
to cheat the night
Never too late to win the day
Never too late to break away
Time will start
to move too fast
But time is now, my friend
I'm a long way from the start
But further from the end
Oh, oh, it's never too late
It's never too late
Oh, never too late
Oh, it's never too late
No, it's never too late